the draft today the most important
match-ups for
week two and i get the first pick since
you got the trivia question wrong and
i'm going to go with the washington
football team they're pass rush versus
kyler murray that is a critical
match up for determining who's going to
come out of that game 2-0 the cardinals
won last week washington won last week
with eight sacks can kyle murray stay
clean this week against chase young and
ryan kerrigan and montez sweat and
everyone else they have who can come
after you five first round picks in that
pass rush chris uh can kyler murray the
first overall pick last year 2019 can he
avoid them that's going to be one of the
big issues for week two yeah i agree it
says one of the ones i had towards the
top of my list too can he avoid those
big awesome physical freaks and not let
them ruin the game like they did last
week for the eagles and everything like
that i think we're both expecting kyler
murray to be smart enough elusive enough
and they have enough of a quick passing
game to where i think we're thinking
they won't get a bunch of sacks on him
but we'll see he lives dangerously and
we know he's a playmaker so that might
you know end up him keeping the ball a
few times thinking he can make a play
and he doesn't get around the corner or
whatever it is all right i'm going to go
to our sunday night matchup
how about cam newton versus jamal adams
i like that a whole lot and i know this
is a lot deeper than just those two guys
but uh it just sounds better when i just
picked those too i mean yeah this is
josh mcdaniels there's pete carroll too
you know matching of wits how are you
gonna stop my new run attack and all
these things i do with cam noon and i
and the reason i pick jamal adams is
because i think he's gonna be
an integral part of being that guy just
like we saw last week he's all around
the line of scrimmage he's blitzing off
the edge he's blitzing between the guard
and tackle gap you know he's the guy
that goes sideline the sideline and runs
everybody down i think that a lot of the
time seattle will set things up to go
hey you got a gap you got to get you got
a gap and we've all got our gaps and
we've all set it up that way so jamal
adams can come through and clean up the
trash just let him go run around and
make the tackle and i think that's the
way they're kind of setting up their
deal a little bit to do that too so
that's where i'm very interested to see
this seattle
always is stop the run first
and new england right now is old school
and goes no we're running we don't give
a damn what you do and it's going to be
a little test of wills there that i'm
very excited to see
i had that game on my list but not that
matchup i went broader big picture bill
belichick versus pete carroll pete
carroll turned 69 the other day
belichick in that same age range pete
carroll said yesterday he's on a
five-year plan so he's going to keep
coaching belichick is going to keep
coaching carol was previously the
patriots coach and was fired really
didn't turn his career around until he
went to usc and i don't know how
criticized that move was when they hired
him people thought oh we're going to
stink now well pete carroll's been one
of the best coaches in all of football
for the last 20 years they've had a
winning season every year since 2012. i
think a real
battle of the brains as it relates to
game planning and preparation uh
mainly defensively and they're both
defensive guys so that was gonna be mine
but uh let's move to a different game uh
instead of patriots seahawks although
that's one of the biggest games of the
week i'll go to indianapolis because the
vikings get a chance to quickly get
reacquainted with a source of
more frustration than anything else in
recent years xavier rhodes once he got
the big contract he never really quite
lived up to it he got benched from time
to time he'd have blown coverages
it seemed like he was always in mike
zimmer's dog house so xavier rhodes
starting at corner for the indianapolis
colts versus the vikings receivers that
this is either his chance
to stick it to zimmer or
it's zimmer's chance to exploit all of
those things about xavier rhodes that
drove him crazy either way we're gonna
find out when they get together on
sunday yeah that's right we are he's in
a similar defensive scheme that he was
with zimmer there he doesn't have to
match up and play man-to-man a lot i
will say with xavier rhodes he does look
like he's thinner and lost weight to
where he's moving a little bit better
but yeah i would expect him to be very
motivated and he's going to want to
prove to his old coach and team like you
made a mistake letting me go and all
those type of things
uh and of course he's going to have two
guys that are they're pretty talented
thielen and jefferson
uh they're
you know i like what i saw from
jefferson he's a rookie at a few catches
and we know thielen is you know one of
the better receivers in the game all
right
i'm going to go to one that's like
it's only sexy on one side but i think
it's a crucial match up for the week i'm
going to that eagles rams game we talked
about it a little earlier
there's issues in the interior part of
the offensive line with philadelphia
aaron donald is going to be matched up
with an inexperienced matt pryor number
69 at right guard and i would expect
that any big situation they're gonna
make try to find a way to go okay hey
it's third and seven we know they're
going to pass let's move our d-linemen
around to where aaron donald's matched
up on that guy
and make it schematically hard for them
to help out on that guy and i think that
to me is something i'm going to watch
out i mean aaron donald ruins games like
you just we talked about earlier against
one of the best offensive lines in
football with the dallas cowboys what's
he going to do against an offensive line
that is spotty at best with pass
protection a quarterback that holds the
ball too long at way too much
and that that could be the difference in
the game it really can if wentz can uh
not get strip sacked fumbled and maybe
not take so many sacks the eagles eagles
can win it but if this is one of those
things where he's trying to make plays
and he gets sacked four or five times
and fumbles the ball once or twice
they're gonna lose and it'll probably be
aaron donald at the center of all that
chaos
you know and it's another game where you
and i look at the same game and have
different matchups that are intriguing
and this one involves guys who would
never be on the field at the same time
but it's jared goff and carson wentz the
top two picks yeah good one 16 draft and
and and they're both still not i mean
think about it 2015 jameis winston
marcus mariota neither got a second
contract both finished their five-year
runs with their original teams but now
they're back ups
wentz and goff got big contracts
but here we are a year later and i still
don't think we're 100 sure they deserve
the title of franchise quarterback and
this is a good measuring stick to see
where those guys currently are going
head-to-head because
starting in 2017
that's when
we've had this overflow of incredible
quarterbacks and we've just kind of
forgotten about goff
and wentz having that draft pedigree
they're just kind of there they don't
get mentioned with patrick mahomes lamar
jackson kyler murray the truly deshawn
watson all who have come after them so
i'm i'm fascinated by that matchup even
and that's not my official pick uh it
just flows out of that same game my
official pick for this one
is uh julio jones against the cowboys
secondary because you know early in that
rams cowboys game it was robert woods
robert woods robert woods and i think
they could have gone to robert woods
even more than they did he was only
targeted eight times six catches for 105
yards julio jones had 150 or more than
150 last week against the seahawks i
don't know if the cowboys can handle
julio jones if they can't handle robert
woods they can't handle julio jones and
and we just assume cowboys coming home
they're gonna have about 20 000 people
present they should have won the game on
sunday
i'm not writing off the falcons just
because they got beaten soundly by the
seahawks because the seahawks may be the
best team in the nfl this year they
could be and let's not forget it was in
the third quarter it was 14 12 on a
fourth and five the game was still very
much in the balance and then russell
wilson just made an unbelievable play
and the game turned from there with the
big touchdown pass to dk metcalf so i
hear you i mean that you talk about like
a big game falcons cowboys here we are
week two you two teams start out oh and
two
whoa
so that that is something to watch out
for certainly and julio i think is a
little banged up too right mike so we
don't even know i mean i think he's got
a little bit of strength
hamstring yeah we'll see where that goes
all right
i don't like to do this but i'm going to
do this because i'm not i don't want to
double dip in games but i just can't
help it with this one do you see any
peas on my plate no i don't go ahead all
right so dk metcalf that's first stefan
gilmore
that's where i'm gonna go they're back
to the same game i know i'm sorry maybe
we need to make a rule double dipping
for now on but it's too late for this
one dk metcalf the go-to target for
russell wilson russell wilson's making
comments like he's the best receiver in
football
stefan gilmore is viewed by most as the
best corner in football the
pat the patriots play man-to-man a lot
so that is one i'm gonna be tuned in to
see because they're gonna put pressure
on gilmore uh with seattle because
they're gonna attack downfield with that
passing game and deep passes that
russell wilson could throw so great to
dk
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports